[Musique]
quand l'été est arrivé positifs sont
tous transférés ici à la direction de
santé publique et l'a rapidement
quelqu'un les apps est en apparence dr
c'est hôpital de sherbrooke fourmis de
personnel chacun ici est engagé dans une
course contre la montre pour éviter que
le virus se propage dans la région à
cause de nouveaux cas dépistés
ici c'est le coeur de l'opération de
traçage j'aimerais faire la fête avec
vous des fois ça va très bien les gens
sans doute mais d'autres fois ça donne
un choc et puis ça demande un peu plus
de doigté et de soutien c'est donc avec
délicatesse que ces infirmières doivent
essayer de remonter toute la chaîne de
transmission du virus
il faut reculer pour trouver le râle a
dit la source où la personne n'aurait pu
parce qu'on peut faire dévier avec
d'autres enquêtes ou un milieu travail
pilote partie compliquée c'est bombay
depuis vous avez des symptômes on recule
un peu avant 11 6 on ne put transmettent
pendant qu'on est asymptomatique
quels sont les contacts c'est un
questionnaire de 13 pages avec beaucoup
beaucoup d'informations et cette tâche
n'est pas toujours facile au tout début
on avait des gens de retour de voyage
qui avaient fait plein d'activités
sociales
il y avait beaucoup de contact qu'une
personne pouvait générer 50 actes
imaginez lorsqu'il y a des dizaines et
des dizaines de nouveaux cas dans la
région de montréal par exemple
ce traçage deviennent alors
exponentielle c'est un peu ce qui manque
lorsqu'on parle beaucoup de benoît maes
sait de quoi il parle il s'est occupé du
traçage en guinée alors qu'un vaccin
canadien contre l'ebola y étaient
administrés il faut accompagner de
dépistage avec le suivi des contacts le
traçage tous doivent faire excessivement
rapide pour un cas positif
en moyenne il faut que dix membres de la
santé publique entre en contact avec les
personnes qui auraient pu fréquenter la
personne contagieuse
on mobilise tout le monde dans l'équipe
de protection de la santé des gens et de
faire des enquêtes
même si dans d'autres domaines nous
infirmières scolaires qui sont dans les
écoles nous l'infirmière qui vaccinent
nos infirmières travaillent auprès de
développement des enfants
bref toute une série d' équipes partout
sur le territoire
henry ici à sherbrooke on a donc recruté
une véritable armée d'enquêteurs qui
aujourd'hui sont surtout en télétravail
au plus fort de la crise plus d'une
cinquantaine de personnes passaient
leurs journées à joindre et appeler les
longues listes de gens potentiellement
contaminés et tout ça en quarante huit
heures au moral on veut pas se permettre
d'avoir un test sur une piste de ski
plein de trois jours à venir
adresse aux claquettes on envoie des
courriels ya pas de réponse et un autre
de trois jours au plus après sol de
faire tester les contacts on peut pas
permettre que tout se soit très lent
l'estrie durement frappée au début de la
pandémie
peut-elle faire profiter montréal de son
expérience alors que la métropole est
devenu l'épicentre des ravages du virus
c'est plus complexe étant donné le
volume d'informations à montréal et puis
ils ont vraiment besoin d outils
informatiques lors plus que tous les
autres régions où il ya moins de corps
mais en attendant que les outils
informatiques soit efficace que peut
faire montréal qui a de plus 5 centre
intégré de santé et de services sociaux
pour gérer la crise
une administration centralisée c'est sûr
que ça a été facile tant ici on a vu que
c'était facile tant en estrie pour
montréal ça peut être une richesse
d'avoir des différents établissements
puis près de la population dans le
quotidien pour aborder les services de
santé plus adapté à la réalité
territoriale
mais en temps de crise c'est sûrement un
facteur qui complexifie l'intervention
la clé passe peut-être par plus de
flexibilité de la part de la santé
publique pour être mieux préparé au
traçage pas seulement à montréal mais
aussi dans les autres régions il faut
qu'ils soient prêts c'est fois lorsqu'on
va avoir une éclosion la can dans une
région qui a laissé le temps
d'argumenter de la note personnelle
parce que le virus conçu de la première
vague
on est encore dans la première vague
c'est que si on lui donne un peu denses
il est excessivement c'est la rattraper
plus ça va pas mal mieux que au début si
raide à faire pour l'instant
l'estrie suisses ont des confinement et
lorsqu'on voit apparaître de notre
dynamique avec le déconfinement balaya
plus de contact malgré que pas encore
beaucoup de cas mais là c'est plus
difficile de rejoindre les jeunes parce
qu'ils s'en retourner sur le marché du
travail pour une bonne portion allant
les défis sont différents
[Musique]
bref la surveillance se poursuit